There are folks in Washington right now who think we should abandon our efforts to support clean energy.
They've made the political calculation that it's better to stand on the sidelines than work as a team...
...to help American businesses and American workers.
So, they said "no" to the small business tax cuts I talked about.
They said "no" to rebuilding infrastructure.
And they said "no" to clean energy projects.
They even voted against getting rid of tax breaks for shipping jobs overseas,...
...so we could give those tax breaks to companies that are investing right here in Wisconsin.
And my answer to people who have been playing politics the past year and a half is...
...they should come to this plant.
They should go to any of the dozen new battery factories...
...or the new electric vehicle manufacturers,...
...the new wind turbine makers, or the solar plants that are popping up all over this country.
And they should have to explain why they think...
...these clean energy jobs are better off being made in Germany or China, or Spain...
...instead of right here in the United States.
See, when folks lift up the hoods on the cars of the future,...
...I want them to see engines stamped, "Made in America".
When new batteries to store solar power come off the line,...
...I want to see printed on the side, "Made in America".
When new technologies are developed and new industries are formed,...
...I want them made right here in America.
That's what we're fighting for.
That's what this is about.